starting off this hours Texas Ashlee's
calling hey Ashley how are you how are
you
better than I deserve what's up I have a
question I wanted to make sure that I'm
on the right track and I'm following the
Financial Peace University it with your
advice I'm with my husband and I we're
going to purchase I'm on the planner
purchase a home cash paying us off debt
of course at first and I want to make
sure that I'm bill should be
contributing to the forum on cake with a
measure at least 1% and wanting to know
if seven years is too long to be saving
cash for that home close generally I get
nervous after three so seven starts to
make me real nervous I guess the younger
you are the more sense that would make
if you're 50 and you're going to wait
seven years to start saving for
retirement that scares me if you're 20
it doesn't scare me as much do you
understand those years with Hank I'm 32
and my husband 36 and two of those years
are paying off $100,000 worth of debt in
the next two years
oh so two of the seven is not is maybe
step two not baby steps yeah okay well
all right that helps because so that
really because basically what we're
talking about is we tell folks get out
of debt baby step two wanting to build
your emergency fund baby step three then
start saving 15% at baby step four
before people get to baby step four
sometimes they pause there and save up
for a down payment or even though as far
as your going and save up and pay cash
we call that baby step 3b we try for
that not to be much longer than three
years in most cases depending on the
situation so um five years is what
you're saying from the point you have
your emergency fund in place until you
have enough saved to pay cash how much
are you saving for the house I'm two
hundred thousand where do you live in
Texas uh he's infected okay I guess it
would depend on the neighborhood in
Houston Texas all right
the what goes through my mind that's
okay if you want to do that as long as
you stay with it and
when you buy your home you're
immediately at baby steps seven and so
you start loading up your investments
from 40 years old and on it's not 15
percent anymore it's everything's maxed
out because you don't even have a house
payment so if you do your plan that's
what I would do an interim step you
could do there's two possible interim
steps
I don't borrow money as you've heard and
obviously that's what you're trying to
do is to pay cash for a house so an
interim step would be to buy a house or
a smaller house earlier and then trade
up three years later with cash you could
do that or a little nice little condo or
something just get something where
you've got if you pay cash for a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollar condo
and then three years later you moved up
to a two hundred thousand dollar or two
hundred thousand dollar house with cash
that's probably going to get you to your
plan faster by the way because you don't
have any house payments 15-year mortgage
and the interest well that's that's the
other option I don't borrow money but I
don't yell at people as you know for
taking out a 15 year fixed where the
payment is no more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay and so mathematically
philosophically I don't borrow money so
it's not an option for me mathematically
if you can save up and pay off I pay
cash for a house into two hundred
thousand and five years you could pay
off a mortgage of that in five years if
you can save it you could pay it off and
so if you put down a big down payment on
a nice 15-year fixed and then you
hammered it and it was paid off at
exactly the same time you would have
paid cash but all during that time you
own the house that's not a bad thing
that's not a that doesn't put your
picture in the stupid column you know
that's that's that fits with what we
teach but it's the only thing I'm so
freakin boring because I'm so consistent
a hundred percent of time I do what I
tell you to do uh uh you know or I have
done it one of the two or I am willing
to have done it or that kind of a thing
so uh but the only exception of that is
I don't borrow money for anything ever
under any circumstances there is not
anything
that's ever gonna get me back involved
with some but banker I can't stand them
I don't want anything to do with them
they took everything they take
everything their buildings are huge and
your houses are small I'm tired of them
I don't want any debt and so you know if
you guys want to go into debt on
mortgage I don't yell at you for that
but I'm gonna make fun of you if you
lease your car
I'm gonna call you stupid if you're
using a credit card
I mean I'm gonna you know that it's not
but the one thing I'll give you a little
slack on is a mortgage but then turn
around put it on fifteen-year and try
and get it paid off in seven and the
average total money makeover follower
Financial Peace University graduate that
place through and actually does the
stuff is paying off their home in 7.2
years the average millionaire in America
the 10,000 millionaires that we studied
pays off their home in ten point three
years that's the average nationally so I
paid off home is an indicator that
you're heading towards wealth and the
formula is real simple just stick a
house payment into an investment
calculator and see what it becomes after
25 years in your Roth IRA mutual funds
millions and millions of dollars tada
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income so that's where all that
comes from so good discussion actually
good discussion thank you for bringing
up the question and the clarifications
on how to do things and guys here's the
thing what I have what you need to grasp
about what we're teaching around here is
always why we say to do something you
you know we're not a cult leader you
don't blindly follow what we teach you
need to understand why I'm saying to do
this and you go yes that is the truth
that makes sense so I'm going to do it
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good